Thanks for taking me out Mike!
Uh what? I can't hear you.
Huh?  It's so loud in here.
You look really pretty.
Fuck you.
You look shitty.
Uh, no.  Can we go somewhere else that's not as noisy?
What?  I'm from California.
Can we go over there?
This seems a little better.
I know, it's so loud over there.
I said Monday, Wednesday, Friday I wear the skeleton shirt!
It's fucking Saturday!
Hey you can suck my fucking dick man!
I can eat your dick if I want to!
Want to find a place to go an talk?
You own a hawk?  I've never seen one.
Uh, lets try to go over here!
Okay.
If you had to pee, why didn't you go while we were by the bathroom?
No no, I like to be the little spoon.
You know?
What?  You think we're moving too soon?
You want to move in together?
Wait what? That's so racist.
What?  No!
I think I'm falling for you.
Oh, that's a song that just stops the music...okay.
Uhm.  *clears throat*  That's...
Do you mean it?
I mean, maybe.
You say a lot of weird shit.
Oh my God, I would love to see your tits.